hey guys merry here given Jess and EDD
in Australia a break to give you the top
five news stories of the week to get you
ready for your weekend let's get started
if you got your hands on the Star Wars
Battlefront beta this week you'll
probably be interested to know that EA
and dice have announced a season pass
that's right as expected from dice games
dice and EA announced star wars
battlefront will be getting a season
pass this season pass will include 4 DLC
packs early access to each expansion a
new shoot first emote at wausau and of
course a fifty dollar price tag if you
plan on getting the season pass you
might want to consider picking up the
ultimate edition yay haven't announced a
price for it but it will include the
season pass as well as the game I don't
know about you but fifty dollars for
season pass it will know that much about
seems a little steep after watching
Jason X you know the one where he's in
space you probably thought to yourself
well there's no way they're ever gonna
top this but consider a 1 vs 7
asymmetrical Friday the 13th game
everyone vs. Jason Voorhees it just
might be better one player will control
the unstoppable Jason Voorhees while the
other seven control [ __ ] camp
counselors who try to survive the night
the game takes place in the semi open
world of Camp Crystal Lake from the
movies unfortunately if you are hoping
to play this in time for Halloween
you're gonna have to wait until next
year but if this has you hooked be sure
to check out this game's Kickstarter
page a pledge of 25 bucks will guarantee
you the game when it's available do you
remember when call of duty live tweeted
a fake terrorist attack to pimp black
ops 3 well one of the devs is finally
apologizing on behalf of their crappy
marketing gene Jason blundell treyarch
producer shared his apologies with IGN
here's my view and again I'm a simple
director not involved in marketing at
all however it was absolutely not done
for any kind of attention in any way it
was not done maliciously or is any kind
of scare tactic I personally am very
sorry for anyone who looked at it and
got the wrong idea because it genuinely
wasn't meant that way we appreciate his
apology but Activision still is not
commented on the tweet
activision check with your marketing
stress are you as pissed as I am about
silent Hills getting cancelled well it
sounds like Guillermo del Toro might be
just as pissed as both of us speaking to
horror site bloody disgusting com del
Toro said that its cancellation makes no
[ __ ] sense and that the game would
have been remarkable we had a great
experience and great sessions with
hundreds upon hundreds of design some of
the stuff that we were designing for
silent Hills I've seen in games that
came after like the last of us which
makes me think that we're not wrong we
were going in the right direction the
thing with Kojima and silent Hills is
that I thought we would do a really
remarkable game and really go for the
jugular well now that kojima is no
longer working for ko na me maybe you
guys can get together and just make a
game in a game and our top news story
for the week is all about nintendo's new
console according to The Wall Street
Journal Nintendo is done out software
development kits for their upcoming
platform codenamed the NX details are
still scarce but Wall Street Journal
sources say that it could use a hand
held in conjunction with the console
that can be taken on the road the source
also went on to say that the NX will use
industry-leading chips in the device a
sounds pre vague to me but I think it's
safe to say that the NX will be more
powerful than the wii u and that's a
good thing we reached out to Nintendo
for further details on this end and as
you'd expect Nintendo told us to [ __ ]
off just kidding they told us a big
comment on it next year I guess we'll
have to wait to see what Nintendo has
come up with at a later date so those
are our top five news stories for the
week and next week is a huge week for
releases there's Assassin's Creed
syndicate bears guitar hero and just
dance and tri Force heroes so you're
going to want to check back for the
latest have a great weekend